on reste euh à 200 km 250 km de de Kiev
pour retrouver crack notre correspondant
dans la région Gulliver est-ce que vous
avez encore accès aux communications que
sait-on de cette frappe russe sur la
tour de télévision de Kiev
on sait ce que le ministère de
l'Intérieur a confirmé surtout à savoir
que la tour à bel est bien été frappée
et que à cause de cela le signal elle
était interrompue mais ils ont assuré
que ils ont d'autres moyens de
transmission pour les télévisions
ukrainiennes et que donc bientôt le
signal devrait être rétabli en attente
de voir si cela va fonctionner et je ne
sais pas si c'est lié à ce qui se passe
avec les combats mais depuis deux jours
j'ai nettement plus de problèmes avec
Internet qu'on avait jusqu'ici dans ce
village mais cela peut être aussi dû au
fait que il y a plus de monde dans les
villages dans ses campagnes qu'il
n'avait avant à cause du fait que
tellement de gens ont fui les grandes
villes
on est au sixième jour du conflit où en
sont les combats pour l'instant à cette
frontière avec la Russie
et ce n'est pas uniquement à la
frontière maintenant qu'il y a des
combats il y a des incursions russes
dans le sud de l'Ukraine avec la ville
de Herson ville stratégique qui est à la
débouchée du fleuve nietre que les
Russes visibles mon veulent prendre ils
essaient aussi d'encercler et de prendre
la ville de Mario Paul ils ont avancé
vers Marie-Paule depuis l'ouest en
prenant l'autre plus grand port sur la
mer d'Azov bergence on a vu une vidéo
hier impressionnante citoyens de perdues
occupation qui chantait qui disait aux
soldats russes de partir mais il reste
seulement quelques kilomètres vraiment
quelques dizaines de kilomètres pour
arriver à marion-paul en venant vers
depuis l'ouest et depuis l'ouest Mario
Paul était déjà pratiquement sur la
ligne de front avec les forces russes
juste de l'autre côté dans l'enclave
séparatiste que la Russie contrôle
depuis 2014 à donuts donc il y a ces
cibles là au sud au nord archives a été
très sévèrement bombardé aujourd'hui je
pense que beaucoup de gens vu les images
il y a beaucoup de civils qui sont morts
je pense que on a soulevé ingra jamais
assez que archives est une ville
russophone c'est la plus grande ville
rusophone de l'Ukraine comme quoi la
prétention de Vladimir Poutine de
vouloir protéger les les Russes font du
crâne s'avèrent avec ce bombardement de
archives complètement s'il y avait
encore quelqu'un pour le croire je pense
que c'est vraiment la preuve que il n'en
est rien et Kiev qui est encore sous les
bombes je reçois les tirs d'artillerie
plutôt je reçois sur mon application
mobile tout le temps des alertes à la
banque qu'on voit les sirènes sont à
Kiev parce que j'ai une appli comme
habitants de Kiev qui entend normal sert
à des choses bien plus quotidiennes que
de devoir aller se réfugiés dans des
abris